what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to an
episode of pearl daily where I cover
this week's treachery debauchery and
craziness before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and guys if you
want to be the ultimate alpha male
having women coming up to you left right
and center and just talking about how
awesome you are get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today we are
going to be shipping these very soon so
get in to join in on the fun and get
yourself a women's [__] about t-shirt
and also guys we're doing a meet up this
Sunday in London at flat iron grill so
if you want to be a part of that sign up
to our email list that is in the
description and we will be sending out
the information okay so starting out hot
guys you know a lot of you guys said
Pierce Morgan would never have me back
a lot of you guys said well you should
never go on Piers Morgan again
because you guys saw what happened to me
last time they straight up ambushed me
I I thought I was going on to have a
friendly convo with Pierce
and he he went up and just started
attacking me you put a video like that
up and there are going to be some
impressional young ones going hang on
what's Pearl saying Adolf Hitler not
saying he's a good guy but I want to
know why the more conspiracies I I
theories I hear the more I have to think
about it but I took that to me I took
that to mean that you agree with it why
did you cut off the end of the end of
the song I said but we can't even have
the conversation what is the
conversation you want without being
canceled before the left and the right
point is any speech that I think it's
not anything it's not any speech what is
the conversation about Hitler and
conspiracy theories and the Holocaust
that you want to have I don't want to
have any conversation my Lane is
feminism that's what you're singing
about adults
I want anybody that wants to speak on
social media to be able to speak about
what they want to talk about getting
banned whatever they want to talk about
during Holocaust to know if they want to
talk about that as long as they're not
inciting violence I think people also
inciting violence
so you know I was a little nervous you
know and confused actually I was like
they're never having me back but they
did okay
um and honestly I'm a forgive and forget
type of gal all right one Ambush we can
work through it you know so I went on
Pierce Morgan to talk about Russell
Brand so as you guys may or may not know
Russell Brand has had a ton of accusers
come out against him basically saying
that he has committed rape sexual
assault and you know all of the stuff
they just generally throw out these rich
and these famous men okay and it's
always the same thing it's like 10 years
later later these chicks that had
consensual relationships convince
themselves that they were assaulted I
mean I'll give you guys like six months
to report it if you don't report it
within six months I where is the
confusion how how do you not know if you
were assaulted and then they'll come
come out and say I didn't know I was
assaulted what that means is feminists
got in their ear and convinced them that
it was assault I mean guys you know what
they've done is they've expanded the
definition of all of these words to make
them subjective for example abuse is now
emotional abuse now there's Financial
abuse so they expand the definition so
much that we don't even know what it is
anymore they did that with sexual
assault and rape it used to be forced
sex now it's sex without consent
one is subjective one isn't
I mean because who determines what
consent is and so Russell Brand has had
all of these accusers come out and you
know guys I'm not saying
definitively that he didn't do it okay I
mean it's possible Right but
we just start to see this Trope too many
times where men that are rich and famous
get women that falsely accuse them
of stuff that happened years ago and it
all and it just seems like a bitter ax
now imagine guys imagine if women if
there's any women watching which I don't
even think you guys exist but women that
watch the show imagine if you gave the
opportunity to all of your ex-boyfriends
every guy you've interacted with to
throw you in jail
now let's go women right I mean maybe
some of you have brothers imagine you
have a brother and every ex-girlfriend
of his has the opportunity to throw him
in jail you don't think especially a guy
that's been with thousands of women
hundreds of women you don't think
there'll be one taker
and honestly this is the downside of
living a super promiscuous life for men
is that they become rich and successful
later and all their ex-girlfriends
magically believe that now they were
abused okay so I went on Pierce Morgan
and he asked me my thoughts and I'm
gonna show you guys what they were hold
the clip well and you're telling me that
a guy that has women throwing themselves
at him 24 7 had to rape somebody that
doesn't make sense to me well I don't
think I don't think you can make the
leap that that couldn't happen I didn't
say it couldn't I'd say it's very
unlikely like it's Elon Musk is he gonna
rob a bank probably not I think it's
certainly less likely but he could do it
quick
he had thousands of women yeah but he
decided he had to go and pick up a 16
year old from school like I don't have
to see him convicted in a court of law
to believe these accusers because these
specific accusers are credible
and this is the problem when you have a
dating pool of women that really are not
gold they're silver bronze and below so
you know are you feeling unsure about
your finances these days you're not
alone that's why noble gold Investments
is here to help just hear it straight
from the folks that they've helped the
noble gold crew walked me through
everything no stress with their help I
can finally sleep easy at night and now
this month Noble gold Investments is
handing out our free 5 ounce silver
America the Beautiful coin if you
qualify for an IRA invest in gold and
silver with Noble gold Investments go to
noblegoldinvestments.com that's
noblegoldinvestments.com they're the
only gold company that I trust back to
this legal system guys essentially
feminists have infiltrated the legal
system and this is what they do and you
see women do this just in normal
conversation where they change the
definition of words so feminists women
got in and they changed the definition
of words so it loses meaning I'll give
you an example so abuse used to just be
a man hitting a woman right but what
they do is they say no no no there's
more things that we include in abuse and
the things that they include for abuse
only count for men forcing women to do
things forcing women to do things or
pressuring women to do things they don't
want to do but never vice versa imagine
if men could press charges for coercing
them into marriage in a family how many
men get married because they just want
to make their woman happy
uh is that coercion
um and so what they do is and they
expand these definitions so they add in
um Financial abuse emotional abuse like
what is emotional abuse what about a
woman crying over nothing is that
emotionally abusing the guy because you
know he's sympathetic to you why why and
that's why I say if you are pushing that
emotional abuse is real
you were just as bad as the feminists
you were you were I don't want maybe I
won't say that if you are pushing
emotional abuse you are acting in a way
that is enabling feminists now I I'm not
saying everybody understands this or
knows this right everyone wakes up at
some point but the truth of the matter
is everybody has called Stephen Crowder
an abuser for months now last night I
went over a lot of the evidence with you
guys proving that Crowder is not an
abuser so about six seven months ago the
daily wire and Stephen Crowder got into
a disagreement so essentially the daily
wire offered Stephen Crowder a 50
million dollar contract you know I guess
Steven came out came forward and talked
about details of this contract he didn't
use the daily wire's name but I mean in
the conservative media space it can be
very much inferred about who it was and
he accused them of a couple things I
didn't read the t's and C's and I I
don't uh you know we don't actually see
the contract so we don't know but he
accused them
love is somehow stifling the ad rates of
all the creators which if they do that
I'm upset increase my address
um and then the second part was he
accused them of punishing creators if
they get demonetized on YouTube and he
felt like that was being in bed with big
Tech he felt like if you punish creators
for getting demonetized on YouTube
therefore you're cooperating with big
Tech and you're not really freedom of
speech you can say your freedom of
speech but if we don't push freedom of
speech to the limits then you can't
really say you are now I'm kind of in
the middle here I'm not really for
talking about personal business
contracts I understand where Crowder was
coming from but at the time it kind of
rubbed me the wrong way Crowder ended up
leaking like
um a phone call where the owner of the
daily wire
insinuated that you give them slave
contract I don't I don't know who cares
that's not even the point of this
um they get into a fight right and a
couple of months later Candice oh covers
this story and
um so they get into a fight right
so they're in a fight right and honestly
I'm like he just kind of pissed off the
wrong people now Candace did have a
right to defend herself so she came
forward and said no I don't have a slave
contract don't know what he's talking
about she and on top of that she talks
about praying for Stephen that there's
more going on in his life but she's not
at Liberty to say okay
whatever so Stephen takes this as a
threat now was it a threat wasn't it a
threat I don't know I have a hard time
believing
she didn't know about his divorce which
she claimed to but yeah who knows maybe
it was a miscommunication maybe she was
I don't know
um but essentially
this made Steven come out and announce
his divorce so he came out and he said
I'm getting divorced unfortunately
there's people threatening me behind the
scenes and Candace took this as an
insult so Stephen also announces his
divorce and he says he picked the wrong
woman now
I didn't really see a problem with this
I mean if you're getting divorced it
can't be the right woman you know what I
mean like are we gonna argue that's the
right woman she says he's playing the
victim I didn't really see it in this
talk he said he picked the wrong woman
and on top of that he also said not to
go after his wife so I I really did
think it was so bad my opinion right but
Candace then
says to his wife that she can come on
the show and give her side of the story
I thought that was a bit messy you could
say Stephen struck first by getting
Matthew saying she had a slave contract
you know whatever but what I want to
point out that like this is my point
is how women lie and destroy a man's
reputation without showing the context
so what a lot of women will do is
they'll play a clip to play the victim
online and then not show the context of
it so you know I'm asking the question
is Crowder really the monster the media
made him out to be now everyone said
he's this abusive gay man like this this
is the but when I ask like where is the
evidence of abuse and where is the
evidence of him being gay
it's crickets I there's no actual
evidence so you know and guys this is
this guy's business
um and so recently I someone reached out
to me and offered me the full context of
the clip that Candace Owens plays on her
podcast so I'm going to show it to you
um so this is what Candace Owens
reported now guys I'm not even trying to
go for Candace because I mean he said
she had a slave contract and on top of
that maybe she didn't know you know you
got to give people the benefit of the
doubt I don't know who knew what I just
think with this new information people
should see the full story so go ahead
call to watch it's especially difficult
to watch because in this footage she is
eight months pregnant
um and the video essentially reveals
just how emotionally abusive he has been
and she is alleging that he has been
emotionally abusive to her and this
video all but confirms it so let's first
get to the footage I'm just going to
allow you to watch it in its entirety
gradual boundary
I do a boundary
no no you just you just did it I drew a
boundary of you you are not taking a
card because if you refuse to do right
for things then I will go pick up the
grocery list
stinks wood pellets my grill
I know it's not a reasonable effect
how about you first
how do you respect yes other than that
I'm a man
can you see the [__]
no you're not picking up
you are not and I will ask someone
would you like me to ask right
give him an Uber
okay Stephen I can't
feeling some constraints like I can't
see it like listen to me listen to me
you want to walk out right now listen to
me I can't go to the gym I can't go to
my parents I can't call my friends I
can't go I can't be home you're gonna
take the car and leave me here Hillary
just think of how boxing has made me
what do you need me to pick up I'll get
it I'll be back on and back either
[Music]
yeah
there you go you throw your hand you
give up so easy
you give up so easily I just said the
only way out of this is discipline or
respect assistant no we are out of it
okay I love you but Stephen
sick
watch it sit watch it
watch it
okay
I need some space
okay I love you
I love you very much
I don't want that's the big problem I've
never received love from you and the
fact is when I go look I need to do a b
c and b just because now what I love you
more than life itself okay
Hillary you're right we're then Pastor
someone
dead
worthy of a life worth no matter the
wife
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not gonna engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get texting
what you need I'll get you to TV
I
I love you
I commit it to you
let's move on
I'm not into I'm not trying to are you
coming up to do those things you're not
committed to anything you're not
committed to anything
together
okay so it says as Crowder heads inside
Steven gets angrier and angrier and by
his own admission screams I will F you
up at his pregnant wife Hilary who then
flees their home okay so this is a very
harsh accusation and I wanna I wanna
point out a couple things that when I
saw the clip he kept saying
stop calling me abusive like this is
like I I just saw something completely
different than everyone else saw
I saw a guy in his own home
asking his wife to stop
asking his wife to stop calling him an
abuser
you know for all this feminist jargon
isn't that gaslighting isn't that
gaslighting to say your abuse is sick
guys I I thought we were conservatives
what happened to sticks and stones may
break my bones but words will never hurt
me that's not abuse it's not uh you
cannot like it you you can maybe think
he shouldn't talk to his wife that way
but really what I saw was if she just
listened to her husband
then it would have been a completely
different scenario if someone filmed
most people's worst moments where
they're in their homes it's not a it
might look bad so now you have a guy
that whose wife and this happens all the
time the feminists will get in these
chicks ears and just tell them these
women that they do no wrong not ask them
any of the important questions and and
the thing is these chicks will go to
their friends tell them one side of the
story because women were very like um
self-centered so we only think about our
side of the story we never think about
the guy's side so now I was given the
full audio after he got in the house
let's pull it
that is the context of that saying if
you go to your friend and you know that
it was not meant that way I'd be married
Stephen threatened to hit me Dr Walker
you want to play those games you want
okay I'll play those games I will [__]
you up okay I'm sorry I didn't either
way too fast that's exactly what
happened I will actually say that what
Stephen is saying right now is exactly
what happened okay
that terrified me and that is way too
far
and it can't but it's way too far to
claim that I've ever been violence you
and you know what I this is let me tell
you something I appreciate okay
I appreciate that the way that he just
communicated what happened to you
is exactly what happened okay I was
louder
now what you need to understand was
you are a
big man
you have never said anything like that
to me before
okay you've never said anything like
that to me before and
it truly scared me okay and I need you
to understand that it truly really
scared me
I understand that you think he was going
to hit you at that moment I I was
walking out the door and then I was
scared to go back into the house would
we admit this I was across the house
when I yelled at you I wasn't even
within a Striking Distance you were not
within Striking Distance correct it was
yell it was so I wasn't even up
physically in her face but here's my
point here's my point
it was bad that he said that yes okay
he shouldn't have said it was wrong I
think you said that he caught himself he
said I didn't mean it that way
he tried to roll it back or where did
you pull it back
now you had a right to be upset with the
verbiage of what he said and how I said
it I'm just saying in hindsight would
you agree that three months of what he
has gone through
is a little bit of an overreaction so I
need to clarify something okay can I
share some information maybe a lot of
progress if you said maybe yes here oh
yes yes oh yes absolutely yes for that
incident yes okay I agree with you okay
this is Crowder getting red pilled in
real time guys he did and this is what I
say it's so funny because the simps will
come in and say that I lead these men to
destruction when this is what
this advice got Crowder
I mean imagine being in your own home
and being accused of abuse 24 7.
and that that's what they're arguing
about is he's tired of being accused of
abuse in his own home and he says was I
near you were you actually afraid I was
going to hit you and what she does is
she's talking about the Duluth model and
what the Duluth model does is always put
the man as the aggressor it was switched
in like the it was switched in the 70s
and so what happened is is they always
presume that in an argument the man is
in the position of power and my question
is
where where is this evidence of him
hitting her ever
and she just said there she knew he
wasn't gonna hit her she wasn't even by
her you know ladies I'm sorry a lot of
the the stories your friends are telling
you are full of [__] they're not true
because women process everything through
our emotions we see everything emotions
first so a lot of our stories we just
see them from our point of view this is
a woman who had a nanny working a
hundred hours a week watching her kids
The Nanny was the primary caretaker the
nanny said that they tried that she
trusted Crowder with the kids more than
the mother
now the his custody could be jeopardized
because of Clips like this and this
freaking simp Army
comes at me because they falsely accused
me of leaking the kids names which is
false on Twitter all of these simp dudes
and they got outraged over that but do
you know what they didn't get outraged
to have a man potentially losing access
to his children I can understand maybe
jumping to a conclusion from the clip
and if you're not familiar with this
type of content okay but we need to
issue retractions like retractions need
to go out because you know this is this
is wrong candy Stones I I do disagree
with that take but overall I do I do
think she gets things more right than
wrong okay you know she was a woman
clouded by emotions whatever we're a
trending topic so it's relevant to speak
on because it's interesting it's
fascinating I am fascinated by hoes I'll
say it I'm absolutely fascinated by the
way the whole mind works the way the
whole Hive works I'm fascinated I cover
it on my show it is trending when Emma
gets up and does a video and says
something like you know I'm it's chic be
divorced before you're 30. it is
absolutely fascinating to see how
someone's Minds can be so warped you
know in the same way that I think it's
fascinating When anybody does anything
crazy or says anything crazy and I cover
it on my podcast you know I am not
knocking it at all I just tell people
what the facts are you can choose this
lifestyle and here is where you are 99.9
likely to lead in your life right you
are probably not destined for marriage
or not probably not Dustin's personal
relationship men are going to not want
this long term you can say it a thousand
times you can have a thousand cultural
examples and women's still got to go out
there and be hoes you know because
they're about they money and about a
cardi B song or whatever it is so yes I
think it is fascinating I agree
I agree with Candace here you know it
really is fast like
I I see you know women used to take L's
in peace okay let's not pretend like our
grandmothers our mothers never took an
Ellen dating never never made a poor
decision okay but they were at least
ashamed
and you know there's something
respectable about shame there's
something respectable about it because
at least you know you can admit all
right that wasn't the right decision
but I do I do feel I do feel shame about
it
um but the problem is in modern culture
is that really not only do women not
feel shame we parade our bad decision
and Market it to the younger women as
good decisions and this is the problem
is you know and we get so much Flack for
just calling water wet the sky is blue
men don't generally like [__]
you know it's better to be more pure
okay so there was a a feminist lady on
Twitter
that was just enraged she was enraged at
Dad's and she said this is why the dads
don't get custody this is why
um you know women are better parents and
she showed a super educational clip from
Jimmy Kimmel it's pulled up can you name
their teachers of course I cannot
what are your daughters birthdays ah why
do you do this to me what about her I
give up any guesses yesterday oh yeah
yesterday
horrible her birthday was yesterday
yes can you name the best friend of each
of your daughters
can you give us the name of their doctor
can you give us the name of their
dentist uh games Dental land
uh what are your daughter's birthdays
yes May 28 2009
okay so now this feminist is coming in
and implying that men are bad dads
because they don't know their their kids
birthdays
and I just thought how this is the most
out of touch comment I've I've seen in
my life
um you're gonna argue with me that men
are are bad or somehow less the fathers
because they don't know
their kid's birthday I'll tell you
something I I don't even know if my dad
knows my birthday he gets him confused
all the time but that's not guys don't
care about the little stuff that's woman
stuff so again you're measuring a dad
you're measuring a dad being a good dad
based on female standards I mean that
that's stuff typically women know and
you're asking men to be women when men
men are men it's so interesting because
and they it's like they demonize men
when they're spending their their and
Jimmy Kimmel didn't do this but this
comment is demonizing men for spending
their Saturday with their family you
know what what did my dad do my dad
would always go to my basketball games
like you know what's so funny my dad
wouldn't know my birthday but he could
tell me how many points we won by at my
sixth grade basketball game he coached
you know what I mean like you know dads
just like different stuff yeah he
doesn't care about a birthday party and
you know what I gotta say in my fifth
grade tournament we did get gold
not silver we're number one baby
um speaking of gold do you want to take
control of your financial future but
don't know where to start Noble gold
Investments understands investing in
Precious Metals may sound confusing but
Noble gold Investments makes it easy
let's hear from actual Noble gold
investment customers the staff answered
all of my questions and helped me every
step of the way no pressure sales
tactics just honest guidance securing my
future is less stressful thanks to Noble
Gold's expertise don't settle for
financial uncertainty they'll suggest
options and if you can diversify in gold
and silver right now Noble gold
Investments is offering a free five
ounce silver America the Beautiful
bullion coin for qualified accounts
don't settle for financial uncertainty
Noble gold Investments has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
and countless five star reviews why wait
vote a noblegoldinvestments.com
noblegoldinvestments.com the only gold
company that I trust
so now to finish the show
Pearl's given advice again Pearl's just
full of advice so my producers went out
and found me some advice to give what a
day
my wife is out getting laid right now
and I never thought I'd be here but yet
I am
you know every day I lose a little faith
in society a little bit
this weekend my wife 38 female and our
daughter 13 female went to visit her mom
I couldn't go because I couldn't get
time off work and we decided it would
just be a girls weekend for them I'm a
firefighter in a large southern city and
I'm on a call and gearing up when our
dispatcher calls in to tell me there is
some emergency I'm not really needed on
the work call so I got my cell phone and
found a bunch of texts from my kid and a
couple from a number I don't have in my
phone in the course of about 11 text
messages I learned that my daughter has
gone ice skating and fallen and broken
her wrist she's in the emergency room
but could not get treatment because no
one can find my wife the number I don't
know belongs to a friend of my wife's
who's gone to the emergency room to sit
with my kid she was The Chaperone for
the girls who's gone skating so I called
this friend and after a lot of hemming
and hawing she admits that wifey has
gone to dinner with some random guy well
we always leave our location shared with
the family because of my job and sure
enough I pull up the address and Google
it and it's an effing Hotel this was 10
p.m and it's almost four hours later she
hasn't answered my text but she finally
did call her kid I have permission and
insurance information and she got a cast
and a referral to see an orthopedist
when she gets home the friend took her
daughter back to her grandmother's and
texted me she said I'm so sorry that you
had to find out this way about a guy's
name apparently it's been going on every
time she's gone home that I haven't gone
meanwhile I've worked countless hours of
overtime to pay off our house take us on
nice vacations and send her daughter to
the most expensive private school in our
city I'm a fool
um okay so I rarely ever recommend
divorce
but I'll tell you why it's actually
important that men divorce or at least
separate from these women
I'm assuming there's no abuse cheating
on his side
you you teach your daughter there's no
consequences for this type of [__]
you know kids aren't stupid and a lot of
times they spend more time with the
woman than you do
so by accepting this Behavior you're
basically teaching your daughter that
this shit's okay
um and what kind of you know what kind
of mother is she If instead of you know
catering to her daughter she's effing
some guy in a hotel
um and it's really it you know I I some
guys probably will would stick it out
for the kids for a couple years you know
I think that's to the discretion of the
guy I mean he knows the daughter better
but uh this is sad and I've heard this
story a lot where women will go home and
they'll cheat at their parents house and
their whole family knows the whole thing
yeah so I would say make sure there's a
really there's there's got to be at
least a separation I know I know they're
gonna call me a hypocrite because Pearl
doesn't believe in divorce well the men
used to separate from these women they'd
like throw them in like a dungeon or
salt okay not a dungeon but they would
you know they'd like throw her in
another house or like an apartment and
say you gotta work now lady and I would
get evidence of everything I would get
evidence of everything you're talking
about in case you have to go to court
because a lot of these chicks when they
you know they're looking for the next
best option they don't usually cheat to
stay they usually cheat to leave so um I
would hire an attorney soon as you can
and protect yourself that's what I would
do
um but
yeah guys you know um this is just my
thoughts on on different situations and
I and I think there's a whole side of
divorce that is not spoken about and I
think for about 50 years we've been
hearing the woman's point of view and
okay
women have gone through some stuff not
much these days but some stuff and we've
heard you but I think at some point we
got to listen to the men and what the
men have to say and really guys the
quality of wives on the market is subpar
it is bad I I don't I think I know maybe
five traditional women that actually
obey their husbands and when the quality
of the wife on the market this is the
Christian conservative women means
having a nanny work a hundred hours a
week to raise your kids for you and you
accuse your husband of abuse 24 7. um I
I think we're in we're in tough times so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments also get yourself a woman
should have vote t-shirt today like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time